like one of the big problems i had when
making my three by three was that
i there were games that i knew i loved
as a kid but then i don't remember [ __ ]
about them
well there's there's some there's
somewhere if you asked me to play them
now i'm sure i could be like i don't
remember exactly what happened all i
know is that i put way too many hours
yes like so uh yeah i mean should we
just get into that then we can talk
about other gaming stuff after
yeah sure sure should we get trashcan i
think our names are still on the boat
all right
all right let's figure it out okay
let's find out who's going to be roasted
oh okay i can see the names okay i mean
let me not look
would you like to give it yeah okay it's
literally my name
and the first one is oh it's gone it's
gone oh it's me
okay i guess okay start starting things
off easy i see
i can't wait this is going to be fun is
there anything you boys expect
on this gaming list i have a film that
league is going to be on there
i have a few yeah far as anything else
goes
league i expect to be on there right um
i don't know what other games you've
played you never talk about video games
i don't talk about video games often do
i you're like you're like hentai
anime hence i animate video games what
video games do i play nice i swear to
god if fate is on here i'm going to be
sure
i'm going to be so angry if fake grand
order is on
yeah i i didn't put fate on here because
i mean i i play
i don't think about putting i did put i
don't know i did think
about putting not fate but uh genjin
impact on there
okay yeah i was really really [ __ ]
into it
in your life okay well then you want to
go through the nine games you have
all right so starting at the top mass
effect 3
tales of symphonia persona 5 zelda wind
waker
league of legends super mario sunshine
metal gear solid 3
subnautica gears of war 2. i look at
this and i'm just like
this is the most random [ __ ] yeah
that's
almost gay you're not expecting like
half of the games you put on here i
honestly i expected myself to put more
anime games on and i'm just realizing
what i haven't really finished any games
i mean the only real anime games on here
is probably
symphonia and persona right yeah and
those are the only like i'm thinking
what other anime type game series are
there
uh that are famous because when i think
of anime video games i'm just like tail
series persona series
yeah uh those are the only anime video
games i've seen
i've actually finished yeah so why
because
i haven't ever played one tales game
i've played tales of okay
oh that's that's the not good one is it
not good one
yeah it wasn't like the one with the the
woman with the
the red black yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i got quite
far in from yeah yeah i got like 20
something hours in and i was like
wow 20 hours into a jlpg yeah that's
impressive that's important i was like
she's so bored
literally like all the fights of the
[ __ ] that's oh yeah welcome to jlp
yeah like i'm completely okay so here's
the thing for the longest time
i really really tried to get into jrpgs
like as a kid
the reason the reason tails is on here
is that as a kid i like
i knew i would love jrpgs and like the
aesthetic and the story and everything
because i love anime yeah the problem is
i hated turn-based battles like
i i couldn't [ __ ] stand turn-based
battles and that would like put me off
getting more than
say five hours into any jrpg because i
would just get turned off by the
turn-based battles
and so i was like as a kid i was waiting
for a game that was an anime game
that just did not have a turn-based
battle system and also random encounters
i [ __ ] hate random encounters as well
okay right i think that was sad wait
wait okay
you say that though but persona 5 is
literally that i know okay persona 5
it doesn't have random encounters but
persona 5 is literally
the game that broke jrpgs for me
because i mean even as someone who
hasn't played it or plays jrpgs
it's still that geodude that i look at
and i'm like i know that's a good game
like
i don't need to play it to know that's a
good thing yeah yeah you just look at it
i won't play it but yeah yeah like i can
see everything about it that this is a
banger of a game
i'm not gonna play it because i don't
own a console that can play it and
honestly do i want to get into that [ __ ]
no but it's like a [ __ ] good game
like
with persona 5 um i don't know it was
it's the only turn-based battle game
where i just didn't get bored of the
battle system and i don't know why it's
something i think it's
it's the theme man it's it's it's it's
it's a bit of everything right because
it just it's really good at tricking
your mind into thinking that this isn't
turn-based battle
that's that's the best way i can
describe which is like the sexiest
animations alive
yeah yeah yeah it's just got like so
many colors the music [ __ ] slaps
um you can like you get different
abilities as you go on and
i don't know like it's it's something
it's it's really good a trick in your
mind to thinking man this is this just
it just feels almost like a rhythm game
at points right right you know it it's i
can't put my words on why that
battle system out of everything just
trumped any other jrpg battle system
um because i can't i can't think of any
other jrpg i enjoy even though
even though i say i'm a jrpg enjoyer
right i have the most basics
so then why did you put tales of
symphonia there specifically
tales of symphonia okay so because for
me if i would have put a tails gate
because i've played
most of the tales games i played one
tales game i don't know what the [ __ ]
was happening
so if you want to explain to me what
it's about because i legitimately don't
know anything i'm sure the viewers who
haven't played it because if i were to
put a tails game on there personally i
would have put zysteria on there
yeah which one's exterior again is the
one after symphonia
okay i would have put uh the only one i
can think of is vesperia
yeah which is which is like i'm just i'm
just throwing out words for conor here
they all sound so similar already
mysterious
yeah i mean it's like final fantasy one
two three four i can follow along with
the numbers
yeah i'm pretty good at that okay i
think i've got that down i know six
comes after five
i'm pretty sure i'm aware of that yeah i
mean i mean the best way i can describe
it it's just basically a
it's just basically anime as anime the
video game like it's it's it's really
that simple jrpgs are just to me i
i know i can get into most jrpgs if i
like the combat and battle system
because it's just anime the video game
right and i like anime
i'm a [ __ ] weeb therefore equation
equals
you like the tales series yeah yeah
right and
um the reason tells of symphonia one
there was it was my
first experience with just realizing
that
whoa you can play a video game and it
feels like you're watching an anime
well this is this is amazing what's up
like i can't i can't believe i've just
discovered this in my life and i was so
obsessed with this right because
it's um these are two of the only jrpgs
i've ever finished but i was so obsessed
with it
that i got to the 80 point as i did with
most video games and then i just
stopped playing it and i didn't stop
playing it because i got bored
i stopped playing it because i didn't
want that experience to end i didn't i
didn't want to see the end credits
and know that that experience was over
yeah so like i stopped playing it for
about
i i held on to that for about two
[ __ ] years
of my life just just just so just so i
know
that i have i have the ending of tales
of symphonia to look forward to in my
life
like that that was that was like the
peak of life right off after this
you must go to hold a nut you're
literally blue ball
the funny thing is so i'm just like
after after about two years i'm like
okay i think it's time to complete tales
of some phonies
start playing it's time to knock yeah i
think it's time to finally not stop
playing
start playing it again and then i
realized [ __ ] i don't know anything i
can't remember anything that's going on
yeah so what did i do
i just replayed it from the beginning
and i was like 80 hours in already
um so i felt like a good 150 160
hours into this game yeah um persona 5 i
actually
haven't replayed okay because it's quite
long
it's quite a long time it's quite a long
game and compared to tales when i was a
kid i had plenty of time to [ __ ]
replay games back then because i assume
persona is probably on your list as well
because you
yeah oh i've played persona 5 four times
you've played it more than me yeah but i
remember the reason persona's on there
is that
out of like a lot of games in my adult
life it
like for the first time in a long time
you know it felt like
i was a kid again and i was just like uh
how how can i how can i put this into
words when i experienced persona 5 i
didn't know
that i could feel this way just just
like
being really excited about just being
really excited about a game and just
discovering in
this new world and uh god i killed my
feelings when i was an adult
and the persona 5 reminded me it really
did it really did
i don't know it was i was just like yo
this is anime and it's a video game i'm
enjoying it again it's it's like it's
like discovering anime for the first
time again right right
and yeah like i i always i always
everyone always told me you know you're
like the soda series you're like
personally serious and i'm just like not
a [ __ ] word it's got turn-based
battles in there why the [ __ ] would i
like that it's got turn-based battles
and they're dude they are like the worst
system of any combat system in any game
like it's like far and beyond one of the
few things i can agree on donkey with
right you know and that's that's like
the big reason why i haven't you know i
i couldn't get into a lot of the final
fantasies never played final fantasy 7.
um i'll probably start playing final
fantasy 7 remake because that doesn't
have turn-based battles
i mean i was telling myself i was going
to play final fantasy 7 for like the
past 10 years
because it's one of those games like i'm
going to play it yeah of course i'm
going to play it
well i mean yeah the time passed
yeah but i mean i remember i did boot up
final fantasy 7 and the first time on on
steam and i was like oh the place
the original one yeah i'm like yeah oh
it's hideous yeah it looks like
absolute [ __ ] i can't do this like cloud
with like the egg beat of hands
yeah yeah it looks [ __ ] horrible now